can you take us through the process of
developing a screenplay and help us
understand what it means and maybe
provide some examples sure uh how fun uh
I I'll talk you through um the process
that I really love so it starts with the
writer and falling in love with the
writer's work and so for me that
typically comes from I've read a sample
or several samples of a writer inviting
them into a meeting greet or a general
meeting and just getting to know them a
little bit and then sharing the the
things that are important to me to us um
K and I are no longer um developing or
producing material um that's not
specifically for for K to write or
direct um but uh some talking about sort
of like earlier uh in in our in our
company and so uh and then so for
example I might say oh um looking for um
a project that um uh has uh a lot of
heart and hard comedy
contemporary High concept um ideally um
involving like a
two-hander uh or it might be like oh
looking for a road trip movie or looking
for something that's set on a college
campus so there might be some markers
and then so I meet with a bunch of
writers you know putting out like the
general mandate and then they might come
back and sayoh my gosh I have this idea
or oh I wrote this script would you like
to read it and so either hearing the
pitch or reading the script uh and then
falling in love with it and and then
depending on where it's at um
developmentally there may be
developmental work that happens and so
um for me personally when I read
material analytically I read it once I
don't take any notes and then I'll read
it a second time and then I'll that will
be my like deep analytical read where
I'm like I'm stopping I'm taking notes
I'm writing in the margins and then uh
and then I'll put a notes document
together and then I'll read it a third
time and be like do I actually like that
thought was that a good thought um and
then I always love collaboration and so
um I'll talk to my colleagues and say
here are my thoughts do they make sense
what are your thoughts and then we might
have like put any uh put um more
thoughts together on paper I'm a big
believer in putting thoughts on paper
versus just speaking off the cuff um as
a writer it's like you've worked so hard
on either this pitch document or on this
screenplay and it's sacred and I really
want to be very very respectful there's
a feedback model that was developed by a
former student of mine at Northwestern
University her name is Allison Tatum and
I have been using this feedback model
and I think it's amazing so it's a three
question feedback model what type of
feedback would you like how would you
like to receive that feedback do I have
permission to give you that feedback so
as a writer you might say give me
everything I want to know it all but
then there are some writers who is like
can we just focus on dialogue in this
past or I'm not certain that the ACT
bics are very are strong enough or I'm
really struggling with this particular
character's emotional trajectory and so
we design together what is the feedback
now I still have my comprehensive
thought document but I also really want
to honor the process proc of the writer
and so really asking about how do they
want to receive feedback and what type
of feedback and getting that permission
is really really critical and important
because I think writers have really been
abused in so many ways it's like here's
a piece of material and like everybody
gets to have an opinion no way not
everybody gets to have like share their
opinion with the writer so we may going
back and forth a couple of times in
terms of further developing the material
and then when we think it's ready then
we make a determination of do we want to
go directly to financiers or
distributors or do we want to attach
additional elements like a director or
Andor actors so that's typically will
involve representation to help determine
what's going on in the marketplace
what's going to make the biggest splash
and then we take that that step yeah I
love that feedback model because then
too you're going to get such a different
response from someone if you know this
is how they work just how some people
are auditory Learners some people are
visual and so if you hit them in the
right way then they're not going to be
as defensive maybe yeah because it's all
about trust building and it's so tender
and so sensitive to create something and
then put it out into the world and going
back to what we were talking about
earlier in terms of having a tough skin
there's an expectation that artists are
supposed to have this tough skin it's
like this is just the business you're
going to get a lot of feedback you know
you just have to take it in and it's
like and I'm like no create healthy
boundaries receive feedback from the
people that you respect and trust that
have your best interests at heart don't
open yourself up because you're looking
for exteror validation it's like be
extremely Discerning about who you gift
your work to and unfortunately that
latter part will come if the work's out
in the world yes then there will be no
no feedback form and and it will be
delivered in various ways yeah and I'm a
big it's like never read the comments
no yeah you don't think that at some
point and I know that it can be painful
but at some point it's good to know how
others perceive it or decipher is this
just a troll or is this somebody that
actually has a point um I have two
thoughts on that one is if comments are
going to be anonymous that I'm like
disregard them because it's it's this
blanket permission slip for people to
like just spew Venom and when I when I'm
reading the comments for someone else
work and I look at them and I'm going to
say something that's probably an
overgeneralization but and you can tell
I'm getting sort of heated about this
where it's like these people are not
informed they actually don't know what
they're commenting about they may not
know the genre they may not understand
the
circumstances and it is coming from a
place of like Brokenness as opposed to
being Discerning and and actually
offering an informed critique so I'm
like forget it don't read don't don't
you as a Creator do not read the
comments if you really feel like there's
going to be value in having a general
sense of what's the feedback is ask
someone that you trust to read the
comments and then give you a summary
that's actually constructive and helpful
but otherwise you're just opening
yourself up to like again Venom that
energetically can be really destructive
to who you are as a Creator sure and we
don't know someone's agenda in the the
comment it reminds me of the '90s talk
shows where you'd have the people up
there and you know talking about
whatever and then you'd have the raise
their hand and stand up and you knew
just Venom was coming and you didn't
know what their agenda was who knows if
they were a plant in the audience but it
would just be the peanut gallery
throwing Tomatoes at somewh exactly and
and you made a a point earlier about
like the way like different people learn
and different people you know like
communicate in different ways it's all
unique so just like in terms of um the
people who comment come from a
particular like those are people who
like to comment but there are a lot of
other people who have thoughts and
opinions but aren't commenting and so
how are their Reflections being you know
heard they're not and so you're getting
a skewed perspective by reading comments
just from the people who like to comment
what does it mean to have a firstlook
production deal oh that means that um a
finance year is going to give you x
amount of money
so that every idea that you come up with
during the term of that agreement
agreement you will bring that idea to
the finance year and I get to say yay or
nay do you pitch ideas first or only
completed scripts when you have a
firstlook deal um it depends on who has
the firstlook deal so as a producer um
uh my partner K Canon and I had a first
look deal at Sony and so we would um we
would do both we would uh pitch like
ideas of like oh here's an arena that
we're really interested in um or a piece
of Ip that we are really interested in
or it's like we were submitted a script
that we fell in love with and then we
we'd submit the completed script as um
as a I'm trying to think like writers
don't really have firstlook deals
they're going to be more in overall
deals but like as a director a director
might have a firstlook deal so they're
also similar to producers um pitching
nuggets or something that's complete in
your case would Sony pay you
upfront yes so typically with a
firstlook deal um the the studio will
make an agreement a one-ear twoyear you
don't really see a three-year agreement
and and then they their part of the
negotiation is how they'll it'll be paid
out it could be paid out monthly or or
otherwise um over the term of of the
agreement is there a minimum number of
ideas you need to bring to them during
that contract the time span um that can
be stipulated
um
it's for our deal that a number of ideas
wasn't stipulated but there's an
expectation as producers that you're
going to be prolific and so you want to
be bringing in a number of projects now
on the flip side there are some studios
that have firstlook deals where they
actually like limit the number of
projects that a producer has so uh which
I know is like some of my producer
friends that's been like really
frustrating for them where it's like oh
my gosh like we really love this but the
studio says we already have three things
in the pipeline and we want us just just
to focus on those three things before we
put more stuff on our development slate
and so uh again it just sort of depends
on the studio and what their mandate
is